Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Oh, WTF? Was ist das?
Ah, meine... war die richtig drin?
Ohne mich schon, warum ich mich nicht höre?
Mal kurz testen, ob das alles stimmt.
Nicht dass es irgendwie Wacker Kontakt hat oder so.
Test, Test, Test...
Ja, scheint alles zu funktionieren.
So, Lautschn... ja okay, ist alles gut.
Exzellent, exzellent.
So spät? Ja, warum nicht?
Ich mein, ich hab gestern auch gestritten bis 23.15 Uhr, glaub ich.
10 glaube ich ja mal ich meine ich habe jetzt urlaub ich habe urlaub bis januar ich habe
urlaub bis 4 januar muss man sich mal vorstellen 4 januar das ist massive pok champ
alle die musik mal kurz checken ob twitch die auflösung kapiert hat ja also noch
jetzt erstellten sieb klar wir müssen ksd service weitermachen wir haben ksd service programmiert
ksd service erweitert ksd service georedundant im rechten zentrum in den usa gebaut da wird
ksd service wird uns noch eine weile begleiten
ich muss mal kurz ganz schnell noch mal ins mondzimmer ob ich ausgemacht habe den fernseher
klickbait warum kann man doch die frage stellen merke alles mit fragezeichen hinten dran
kann nie klickbait sein weil die immer noch die antwort weil immer noch die antwort lauten
kann nein ja denke mal so bis 23 uhr mal gucken mal gucken also mal gucken ob ich das
camp so lange aushalte müssen wir mal schauen das liegt daran ich habe ja heute mal ein
video hochgeladen mit meinem battlefield fazit und da ist hat mich kontaktiert nach dem video
und hat gesagt max uns war das gar nicht klar dass unser spiel so kaputt ist und wir holen
jetzt alle 1300 developer ran nach schweden und fixen das spiel in zwei stunden es gibt
neue maps es gibt neue waffen es gibt alles neu ja ihr habt es zuerst gehört world first
world premiere warum geht eigentlich ach das ist der chat da kann man das der chat nicht
geht das ist ich habe gestern gehostet er geradet das finden das geht der chat hier
bei mir nicht wundere mich die ganze zeit schon was nur bronze was das geht aber da
gehen wir irgendwas anderes hin wenn schon dann aus keks oder so die schweden machen
ja auch ganz gute keks das video das da müssen wir nachher ein paar dinger besprechen von
dem video nicht so sehr nicht so sehr was ich gesagt hat in dem video sondern die comments
teilweise huge pain champ was da teilweise in den antworten also ich meine die meisten
leute sind ja so realistisch und sagen hey selbst wenn ihnen das game bock macht lassen
es einfach mal so stehen aber aber da sind teilweise comments drin
jetzt müssen wir gucken wir gucken wir dann gucken wir dann gleich da sind teilweise echt
schon brüller dabei vor allem der eine war geil der gesagt hat ich bin dran schuld dass
battlefield jetzt nie patches bekommt ja wie bin ich jetzt dran schuld dass das game kaputt
ist oder was warte mal ich weiß gar nicht wo er ist der hier war das der hier ja das
ist auch big brain time big brain time gewesen denn wenn niemand das spiel kauft dann werden
sie auch nicht mehr zeit und ressourcen in die behebung investiert also bin ich jetzt
dran schuld oder was dass das spiel so kaputt ist wie ist er der dir verstehe nicht man
muss ja nicht meiner meinung sein da sage ich ja gar nichts aber das jetzt so hin zu
drehen als wäre wenn man ein video macht darüber wie kaputt das ganze ist jetzt der
grund des eigentlichen problems das ist wie wenn man sagen würde und das ist ja sogar
witzigerweise passiert ich habe letztes in asmongold video geguckt da hat sich einer
über ihn aufgeregt dass seine wegen ihm jetzt seine blizzard aktien runtergehen dabei hat
er nur besprochen was blizzard mal wieder von kack macht was ist das problem das blizzard
der kack macht den kack macht oder dass es einer anspricht wenn ich den kack erst am
anfang nicht gemacht dann wäre es ja auch kein problem gewesen ja finde ich auch ich
habe mir das selbst ein paar mal angehört ich mache schon mal das game an dann ruckelst
dann ruckelst schön also ich muss euch aber sagen also ich weiß erstens nicht wie lange
ich heute spiele 23 uhr aber ich bin mir auch nicht so sicher wie lange wie lange ich
bettel 20 42 wirklich wirklich noch spiele also ich werde jetzt ich werde noch ok also
ich weiß ich werde genau noch zwei videos machen bis sich das spiel irgendwie bessert
das erste video ist leider noch ein sponsored video weil ich dazu gesagt habe da komme
ich nicht drumherum das muss ich machen big stonks money aber hazard zone ist halbwegs
ertragbar im squad und das andere wird sein wo ich mal ein bisschen drüber habe ich ja
gestern im gestern ende vom letzten stream schon gemacht wo ich ein bisschen drüber
rum philosophiere was die denn jetzt kurzfristig machen können was auch nicht so ein großer
auffang ist um da noch irgendwie so ein halbwegs brauchbares battlefield draus zu salvagen
zu salvagen salvage wie heißt das richte man das aus salvage ok salvage salvage was
salvagen kann also dass man dann auch irgendwie gescheites game draus extraiert so zerlegt
ja und ohne jetzt quasi den kern neu machen zu müssen oder irgendwie zu zerstören das
ist jetzt immer das spiel irgendwie noch so halbwegs seine wenn auch dünn vorhandene
aber noch irgendwie vorhandene identität behält so dann spielen wir mal was auf jeden
fall wieder ein bisschen was anderes als ppega 29 ppega 29 ist einfach nur so letzte letzte
reserve wenn gar nichts geht wenn alle gegner pp 29 rumlaufen ey was bei blizzard abgeht
ist nicht normal wisst ihr was ich geil finde bei was bei activischen blizzard gerade abgeht
dass es bobby grad so ein bisschen an den kragen geht nicht dass der typ irgendwie
jetzt also selbst selbst wenn der nicht mehr activischen ceo ist der danach kommt ob der
besser ist sei mal e frage in frage gestellt noch ist das jetzt irgendwie was wo man sich
da freuen kann der hat ja hat er hat da so viel kohle gemacht dass es jetzt nicht so
als müsste der jetzt unter der brücke schlafen oder so ja habe ich dich habe ich dich schon
geändert in origin wir können in squad machen massive big big brain chat wir können in
squad machen wer ist denn da der opa beitscher na da ist er doch da ist er doch nice captain
pang ist am start den entweite ich jetzt weiß ich ob er nicht den kann ich nicht entweite
ich glaube da ist nicht im chat captain pang ich entweite den jetzt einfach mal gucken was
passiert das ist im hauptmenü im hauptmenü lag ist übrigens normal müsst ihr euch nicht
wundern das game geht auf das game geht auf 100 prozent cpu im hauptmenü das ist quasi
new world 2.0 cpu ist richtig hier am schaffen guckt euch das mal an im menü es lädt ich
will nicht dass es lädt weil wenn es lädt dann stürzt es ab das ist schon so alt das
kennt wahrscheinlich gar keiner mehr wenn es lädt dann stürzt es ab moment moment für
alle die es nicht kennen wenn es lädt kann ich nicht spielen ist es das genau einfach
der war seinerzeit voraus der war seinerzeit voraus ich lasse jetzt nicht weiter rumschreien
der war einfach seinerzeit voraus und heute ist es richtiger muskelmann der echte gangster
ja ich weiß ich weiß irgendwas mit hercules hercules beats glaube ich heißt dann ja ruckel
das hauptmenü müssen wir tragen ich habe keine ahnung woran das woran das woran das
liegt das ist in meinem hauptmenü so ah ah moment bettelfeed backt ja immer rum general
display ach jetzt ach jetzt bleibt es auf einmal alles klar hat jemand von euch mal
ausprobiert ob nvidia low latency was bringt oder wie macht man dlss an ach das geht nur
mit rtx ich habe 908 ti ok bringt das was enable plus boost boost ok nice alles klar
so wir spielen wir spielen mal wieder eine runde breakthrough sind alle drin jawoll noch
mal meint habe ich doch mal gucken ich gehe mal aus dem hauptmenü raus hier das geruckele
kann ich mir angucken der zweite patch hat alles gefixt ja wie gesagt die dice hat sich
nach meinem video gemeldet hat gesagt max gut dass du sagst war uns so noch gar nicht klar
wir fixen das jetzt alles dlss ja anscheinend geht es ja mit der 1080i nicht hatte das game
echt einen day 2 patch nö aber ich habe ein fragezeichen im titel und fragezeichen
im titel kaniji bait sein weil man kann immer noch sagen nein stimmt nicht ach captain poggers
spielst du auf dem auf der xbox oder oder du spielst auch auf dem pc dann kann man
hier drüber entweiten ja da gehe ich noch mal raus lief party noch mal entweiten geht
es jetzt und jetzt laden wir das max noch mal ein gucken ob das funktioniert ok wir
können anfangen easy das game hat keine bugs wie ihr gerade gesehen habt das game bräuchte
wenn man ehrlich ist das game bräuchte eigentlich tätsch jeden tag die müssten quasi das
spiel sagen wir mal durchgängig bis nächstes jahr august jeden tag tätschen mit jeden
fast dass da was gescheites bei noch rumkommt ja wenn dir das spaß macht wie gesagt das
spiel hat ja auch seinen moment und ich habe überhaupt keine problem mit wenn das einem
spaß macht im gegensatz zu denen die sagt ich habe meinen spaß aber max du kack spaß
warum kritisierst du das spiel wenn es bei solchen leuten also ich sag nicht dass du
das sagst ne also wenn du weißt weißt du anlass dazu bei solche leuten denke ich mir immer
so hey soweit kann der spaß doch nicht her sein das bräuchte die müssten mal richtig
agil sein bei dais daily daily patch releases auf github oder so continuous integration
akuma ein kaputtender breakthrough server alles klar lief game also wenn ich noch einen in
der liste habe oder wenn noch einer mitspielen will der mich carrying kann dann immer her
damit ja so aber jetzt suchen wir erst mal nochmal natürlich super agil seid ihr noch
drin ja hoffen dass jetzt geht ich habe immer aus dem hauptmenü raus erstens dass ich chat
lesen kann und zweitens weil das spiel ruckelt im hauptmenü im spiel nicht witzigerweise
muss auch mal einer verstehen ich habe übrigens was festgestellt ich reg mich weniger auf
wenn ich beruhigter spreche das ist glaube ich so so mein hirn denkt wenn man ruhig redet
obwohl man sich aufregt dann regt man sich nicht auf und dann regt sich schneller ab
das heißt wenn ich besonders wenn ich besonders beruhigt klinge reg ich mich eigentlich gerade
besonders auf wie wäre es mit einem zweiten monitor ich habe einen zweiten monitor für
den chat und zwischendurch in game nicht sehen wo es geht los aber ihr seht den chat nicht
ihr seht den chat jetzt doppelt ihr seht den chat unten rechts und hier ist quasi chat
seption gibt es nun zwei lmg ja es gibt auch nur vier glaube ich smgs und vier oder fünf
assault rifles und irgendwie nur ein paar sniper und wie viele shotguns gibt weiß ich ehrlich
gesagt auch nicht wie viele shotguns gibt zwei zwei shotguns ja zwei sniper zwei dmr
zwei lmg also die ich freigeschaltet hab da kommt noch was ja hier unten kommt noch
was was und ich glaube vier oder fünf assault rifles ich glaube vier smgs wir spielen heute
mal ein bisschen mp mp9 frei achja forceborn auch am start day two patch hat es nicht
behoben chat sagt kein bock mehr auf das spiel ja also wie gesagt ich kann jeden verstehen
der kein bock mehr drauf hat ich habe ja auch jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig bock drauf aber
es hat halt seine momento so lang es neu ist nehme ich das einfach noch ein bisschen mit
ich meine ich habe immer ein geld dafür bezahlt ja aber ein schnell rennen ist mal wieder
kaputt seck ist das denn warum ist mein schmuck geht mein schnell rennen man also generell
dann schleicht so schleicht so richtig ich habe jetzt sagt er hat fiske sagt er hat
gehört das bett lief ja am anfang auch blöd war und langsam besser wurde ist da was dran
ja also mal ganz davon abgesehen klar du kannst man kann das ja immer noch im internet nachlesen
gibt es ja sicherlich history of battlefield vor oder sowas aber ja das ist so ist laut
genug chat ihr müsst mir mal eins sagen ruckelts ja nein ist laut genug ja nein auf was ist
denn hier los alter die sind ja mal hier what the fuck was ist denn hier los ich habe zu
wenig schuss captain poggers ich kann dich nicht retzen hier ist ja mal hier ist ja mal
sonst was los alter ich versuche mal kurz hier rein zu ok direkt von wo auch immer also
in battlefield 4 war das so der vorteil in battlefield 4 war aber dass du spiel schon
in dem zustand rausgekommen ist wo du erkannt hast dass es eigentlich ziemlich nice ist
bisschen lauter ja und ich sollte die mario musik ausmachen den lauter mache ich so hier
36 glaube ich ganz gut ich habe noch nichts freigespielt für die mp90 das ist bisschen
bisschen pain
battlefield 4 war viel schlimmer am anfang das kann ich so nicht bestätigen battlefield
4 war kacke am anfang mit bugs aber battlefield 4 war vor anfang an ein gutes spiel battlefield
4 hatte halt so viele so also sehr viele kleine sachen wie du bist ins beschleunigt dann gegen
die wand geklatscht und sowas in der richtung und ich glaube in battlefield 4 haben da nicht
am anfang sogar auch die buchstaben am mcom gefehlt und sowas ok das war nicht hoch genug
für mein wingsuit verstehe verstehe battlefield logic battlefield logic ist das jetzt hoch
genug für mein wingsuit ja ich will ausdach ausschütt nice ok clusterfuck ist angesagt
vielleicht vielleicht können wir auf das andere m kommen also ich habe ja battlefield 1 ich
bin mir nicht sicher was ich mir nicht gekauft habe aber wo ich die beta gespielt habe ach
keine ahnung zumindest ich hatte sowohl bei battlefield 1 als auch bei battlefield 5 aber
da komme ich rein und kann raus fliegen mit meinem wingsuit muss mich erst mal ein bisschen
warm spielen gerade also da hatte ich den eindruck die kamen eigentlich im ganz brauchbaren
zustand raus wo fliegst du hin ach das ist dieser kack der granatwerfer ist so mies ist
der granatwerfer das macht übrigens kein damage wie ihr gesehen habt ist ja obvious
dass es kein damage macht also glaubt es ist klar also wenn man von von so hoch runterspringt
dann kann es kein damage machen ob wir es lieb
ok die müssen wissen dass ich da bin es ist zu viel los in dem fucking game
es ist zu viel los man es ist zu viel los mein gehirn explodiert dabei was willst du
da machen das sind keine bots die sind einfach nicht so auf zack gerade ok wir können jetzt
mal big brain tactics probieren pass mal auf wir machen jetzt die massivsten pfeiffer taktik
die ihr je gesehen habt gesehen habt wir nehmen jetzt das spawn bieken wo ist denn das das
da ne spawn bieken wir nehmen das spawn bieken und ja hier ist eigentlich doof ich muss irgendwie
rein fliegen vielleicht komme ich ich flieg rein und setz mein spawn bieken hinten hin
ich muss rein fliehen vielleicht kann ich ich gehe da hoch ich gehe da hoch flieg rein
und setz mein spawn biegen big brain tactics und setz mein spawn biegen hinten auf die
map und dann können wir immer wieder hinten spawn nein nein nein nein alter hier will
ich nicht mein spawn biegen haben hier mein spawn biegen gib spawn biegen ok nice nice
ich hole dich wir sind zum glück hinter die hallo game please ja darf ich das ist ja so
clusterfuck ich habe kein hiel dabei das ist mein problem gerade ok ich muss jetzt
schnell sein schnell guckt euch das mal an zwei sentry guns 20 leute nope no pass ok
das mit dem spawn biegen ist ja an sich eine gute idee dazu müsste ich aber halt mal irgendwie
hinten hinten hinten hinkommen wie ich einfach megafette xp bekomme hier ich müsste halt
in den hell ja nice nice nice nice hier das ist sehr gut perfekt perfekt so ist perfekt
hier jetzt fliegen wir einfach zu richtig krass an arsch der welt so oh nee da ist auch noch
ein hovercraft man jetzt ist direkt ein hovercraft hinter mir ok ich versuchs mal sehr gut ok
jetzt können wir jetzt jetzt sind wir hier am start ok gg easy range nice eine nice range
chat sagt sind extrem viele leute los in die map ist zu offen ja oh danke danke massive
poggers wir haben jetzt wir haben halt hinter mir jetzt den spawn bieten das ist halt alter
diese piste diese piste das ist so schlimm endlich piste ist die smg ich mach mal ein
paar motion sensor hin aber aber das ah ja nice danke danke aber wir haben das spawn
bieten ich hoffe die haben das spawn bieten nicht gefunden die haben nein die haben das
spawn bieten nicht ach wie ist das nice poggers spawn bieten jetzt sollte ich eigentlich jetzt
sollte ich eigentlich das spawn bieten mal auswechseln habe ich richtig richtig nice
nice aktion gemacht aber ich habe jetzt nicht den richtigen specialist für und ich habe
noch das spawn bieten das heißt spawn bieten ist nur einmal verwendbar nee oder echt jetzt
oh das ist dumm ist das wirklich so ja dann dann rib dann rib ich dachte das kann man
setzen lassen na dann ist ja fail ok dann dann hat es doch nichts gebracht aber ihr
müsst zugeben die idee war gut wer macht denn ans hovercraft ein granatwerfer dran
machte nix die idee war gut ja also ich nix normalerweise ist es viel einfacher als
a2 der knatterfuchs ist schon afk im spawn da hat schon kein bock mehr ah jetzt nice
komm mal da da ist der poggers heli also ich will raus game ey es sind halt so viele um
mich drum rum ich muss mich jetzt mal verstecken es sind halt einfach so viele es ist eigentlich
egal wo ich hingehe sobald ich kann einfach ich kann einfach nur motion sensor werfen
ich meine ernsthaft es sind so krass viele ich bleibe jetzt einfach hier oben mit der
stehend du kannst es nicht kontrollieren das ist so dumm kann man schon portal natürlich
kannst du portal spiel du kannst auch neue neue spielmodi machen in portal aber ich kann
es euch mich kann es euch nach der runde mal zeigen wenn man hauptmedien sind es lustigerweise
spielt kaum einer portal da sind meistens 23 server auf mit ein paar spielern drauf
der rest ist der rest ist halt weg also press macht sonst was aber nicht portalspielen
ich glaube es wird zeit für ppega 29 anti anti panzergranate auf macht den panzer platt
macht den panzer platt granate beste ok das funktioniert richtig gut ja das kannst du
mal richtig ach ihr seht die genialität dieser dieses offenen map designs in kombination
mit 128 spieler ok ppega 29 time es bringt jetzt zwar nicht direkt was aber besser als
mit der mp9 hier rum zu hampeln vielleicht kann ich da raus das ist anderes team overcraft
jawoll gib ihm
hey hallo kann das ding mal bitte die lauten jetzt irgendwie ist es möglich das schießt
einfach zu lang schnell einsteigen und weg hier
und was genau wurde ich gerade terminatet mal die pp 28 ausprobiert ja die sagt ich
spiele die pp 29 feuer vom silo ach ja natürlich das trifft mich da ja was auch sonst so ist
ja logisch es war ja total obwies dass dort feuer ist wo ich gestanden habe wir bräuchten
jetzt den er so als richtig geilen heli mann der einfach alles weg basht im heli herzinfarkt
ja das war der hat die hat die backliste auf reddit gesehen hat sich gleich in die luft
gesprengt hat die diese backliste gesehen das riecht krass hat irgendein typ eine liste
gemacht das ist irgendwie keine ahnung drei drei seiten lang ich werde jetzt übrigens
gekriegt ich darf dich nicht retten sehr schön muss den medipen mitnehmen medipen ist besser
medipen hat zwar nur glaub vier charges aber du kannst schneller zünden und hat es hat
nicht so lang cool down ok vielleicht kann ich jetzt wieder von hier mein wingsuit starten
das wäre halt sehr nice nein nein das geht nicht von hier ok irgendwo von hier muss
es gehen ey nein nein lasst mich in ruhe ihr wollt mich ihr wollt mich nein ihr wollt
ihr nein nein nein ihr wollt mich nicht hätten der chat oben denn don't play alter der jub
hat 100 euro ausgegeben ist einfach nur gefrustet über das game das kann ich verstehen was ist
das für eine bescheuerte antwort achtung gibby achtung wir gehen jetzt rein es ist nicht
möglich es ist nicht möglich irgendwas hier zu machen in game chat der ingame chat der
ist immer nur am flamen aber ich kann sie ich kann sie ja nicht verübeln ich kann es
ihnen beim besten will nicht verübeln was willst du machen aber das game ist eh vorbei
gg jetzt immer jetzt ihr wisst umso knapper es war und umso schwieriger es war umso mehr
ist es easy ich finde das ist die beste breakthrough map witzigerweise und leute wenn ich sage
das ist die beste breakthrough map könnt ihr euch schon vorstellen welch genialität
die restlichen breakthrough maps sind erst mal bettel viel dreien machen wo wir gerade
im hauptmenü sind bevor es ruckelt bevor es ruckelt wieder im hauptmenü ich zeige euch
jetzt mal zwei sachen es wird wahrscheinlich ruckeln weil hauptmenü und so aber ich zeige
euch mal portal ganz schnell also ich zeige euch nicht wie portal sondern einfach nur
portal server dass ihr sehen dass eigentlich kaum sich einer großartig für portal interessiert
auch immer ich hab was freigeschaltet pp 29 moment collection muss ich mir mal kurz angucken
hoffe die gamesuche läuft wo ist das ding ich hätte ein pongas hat kein bock mehr customized
Hab ich ihn freigeschaltet hier unten irgendwas?
While moving, ja while moving ist bei dem Ding echt gut.
Hab ich sonst irgendwie einen Barrel oder irgendwas gescheites?
Oppressor, ne, hab ich schon dran.
So Munition wäre ganz nice, irgendeine Gescheite.
Also guck mal hier, ach ich such gar nicht, warum nicht?
Ach dein Game ist gecrashed, ich lade dich noch mal ein.
Merkt ihr das Game ruckelt nur im Menü, wenn ich ein Spiel suche, das ist ja merkwürdig.
Es ruckelt nur, wenn ich ein Spiel suche.
So also ich wollte euch mal kurz was zeigen in Portal, wenn ihr hier auf Browse geht,
ihr werdet sehen, es gibt nicht so viele Server, also das ist ein neues Battlefield, du hast
hier gerade mal irgendwie 5, 6 Server, oder 7, die richtig voll sind, heute Mittag waren
das ganze 2.
Also es hält sich in Grenzen, also ihr könnt von ausgehen, wenn das der Server Browser
von All Out Warfare wäre, da wären bestimmt 100 Server voll.
Ja, da gibt es keine XP, das kommt noch dabei, aber es spielt sich teilweise besser.
Game suche und bei der Gelegenheit, ach ne da sucht ihr noch gar nicht, bei der Gelegenheit
gucken wir doch gerade mal, Battlelog BF3, schauen wir mal ob dort die Server noch besucht
sind.
Wir spielen jetzt kein Battlefield 3, aber die Server sind ja fast voller als sonst.
Sind die Leute alle abgehauen und spielen jetzt Battlefield 3 oder, was ist das, Suche
läuft nicht?
Menü, beste, also die Server sind ziemlich voll, gut es ist heute auch Samstag, es ist
Samstag abends, aber trotzdem, also wir haben 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 8 volle Server und
dann noch 9, 10, 11, also nochmal 3 spielen wir oben drauf.
So guck mal, Battlefield 4, sekunde, ich muss Battle of Honor Warfighter gucken, nicht dass
mich es interessieren würde, aber ich will einfach wissen ob das noch irgendjemand spielt.
Ja, Kill for Skill, jetzt haben sie auch fallen lassen wie heiße Kartoffel das Spiel, als
das zu patchen, das ist auch so ein Ding, so könnte es auch Battlefield 2042, nein, das
spielen wir nicht nochmal jetzt, ok doch, doch wir spielen es nochmal, wir gucken ob
wir besser durchkommen, wenn nicht wird Rage quittet, wie gesagt ich bin der Meinung eigentlich
ist das die beste Breakthrough Map, ach diesmal sind wir Defender, diesmal sind wir Defender,
ok.
So also gucken wir mal schnell Battlefield 4, wie es da aussieht, hol dir jetzt Battlefield
4, nee, hab Battlefield 4 schon, hab Battlefield 4 schon seit 8 Jahren oder wann es rausgekommen
ist, sekunde, wir filtern mal kurz nach, warum heißt das eigentlich alles auf Deutsch, was
ist denn Bindeglied, kann man nicht US oder gibt es EN, gibt es das irgendwie vielleicht
auch auf Nichtdeutsch, so ja besser, haben wir hier Conquest und Rush und Conquest Large,
Supply Filter, was haben wir hier zu bieten, ja guck mal 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, auch
ungefähr gleich viele Server, oh es geht schon los, Chainlink ist das, ich weiß gar nicht
was Chainlink war, war das das wo man mit dieser tickenden Bombe über die Map läuft,
nee das war was anderes, ach nee Chainlink war wo man die Basen erobern musste, in der
richtigen Reihenfolge und das es dann irgendwie Sachen hochgeladen hat, war das das, wurde
es irgendwie abgeloadet hat, aber nur wenn du die richtigen Basen gehalten hast oder
nicht, war das gar nicht in Battlefield, war das gar nicht in BF4, war das woanders, ich
weiß gar nicht mehr was das gewesen ist, war zu lange her, die Pose hier von uns ist gar
nicht mal so geil, weil wir verlieren A1, normalerweise muss man A1 erstmal halten,
ich finde ja eh A1 ist schwerer zu halten, guck mal mal, ich versuche mal hier rüber
zu stelzen, aber ich habe halt hier nicht die geilste Waffe dafür, die Waffe ist so
geil auf Range bzw. nicht vorhanden auf Range, oh was ist da unten, was ist da unten, Bashen
alter Bashen, Bashen alter Bashen jawoll, warum heilt mich das Medikit nicht, ah weil es
ein Cool Down ist, verstehe, das finde ich übrigens auch sehr blöd, dass Medikit so
einen krassen Cool Down haben, ich muss mal ein Wingsuit verwenden, wenn ich den schon
habe, komme ich da rauf, oh Pock, nein, verflyt, nee nee nee so nicht Kollege, hinter mir
was ist denn hinter mir, kommt da was, oh voll in den Kopf, damit hat er nicht gerechnet,
physics over 9000 hier ist das, jetzt, oh jetzt McKay am Start, jetzt hier Webster Crabbling
Hook, das wäre richtig richtig Pock, vielleicht habe ich Glück, vielleicht habe ich Glück,
ja, nein, ok, fast, ok Crab, dein Spiel ist schon wieder abgeraucht, ähm hast du gestern
auch das Probleme, haben die SMGs überhaupt Recoil weniger als die Assault Rifle, wie
lächerlich ist denn dieser Wingsuit, der ist eigentlich ziemlich nice, für dich jetzt,
die Range ist meine Waffe nicht die beste, aber ich will das mal freispielen, äh Captain
Ponger sagt Bescheid, wenn du wieder in Game bist, ach das geht ja nicht, ich kann dich
ja nicht in laufendes Game invite, ne, man muss ein bisschen runterziehen, aber ansonsten
ist das, ist der Control, ist die Controls relativ easy, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss
den Midi-Pen mitnehmen, alles andere ist Selbstmord hier, jetzt haben wir drei Hovercrafts, drei,
ernsthaft drei fucking Hovercrafts, ich wollte eigentlich mich hier hochstelzen, hallo, drei,
so heftig, guck mal, guck dir das an, drei Hovercrafts, drei Helis, ah hi Jungs, was
geht, ist das hier Pepega Station 1, ok dann würde ich sagen, wir haben alles eingenommen,
ach ne, aber gleich, aber gleich, aber gleich, da unten ist noch was, hier, aber sowas von
im Kopf, hier ist doch noch einer, oh das ist ein Panzer, das ist einfach mal ein Panzer
hier am Start, ich brauche Extended Max Leute, ohne Extended Max geht hier nichts, oh da sitzen
aber noch, sag mal, warum sitzen die Gegner in unseren Spawn rein, WTF, was ist mit den
Gegnern los man, diese Gegner sitzen in unseren Spawn, ach Moment, ich bin ja dumm, wir sind
ja Defender, Leute, was erzähle ich denn eigentlich, wir haben es gecaptured, Chat nimmt auch wieder
heute alles hin, was ich sage, oder, wir sind ja Defender, wir müssen uns gar nicht angreifen,
ich sag nur, ja ja wir haben es, ja nice, Scheiß haben wir, wir haben gar nichts, ich denke
die ganze Zeit, wir sind Angreifer, aber so ist das halt, schon spät Leute, fast, es
ist schon spät für mein Hirn, schon spät, guck mal mal, ob wir da wieder hochfliegen
können, oh mein, am Start, schon spät, Alter zieh hoch, wollte nicht, hatte, hat sich
gedacht, nope, ich flieg jetzt nicht, ich flieg jetzt einfach gerade runter, ich hab
die ganze Zeit S gedrückt gehalten, aber hat sich gedacht, nope, will ich nicht, Achtung,
oh die aimen das richtig krass ab hier, den Scythe gerade, so jetzt aber, den hier, der
ist es, nice, hinlegen, hinlegen, oh Ranger, nein nein nein, Ranger, gehst du fort, oh
hey, da kommt er, da kommt er, Achtung, wir aimen den jetzt richtig krass ab, der Sppega
29-Style, hier, bin mir nicht ganz sicher wo er hin ist, aber ich, oh da können wir
mal eine Granate reinschmeißen, da scheint es, da scheint es ganz gut abzugehen gerade,
vielleicht haben wir hier ein bisschen, top, nein, Alter, es ist alles leer gewesen, das
musste er erst mal schaffen, Waffe leer, Pistole der beste, wir hätten die so krass
gerecht, aber nein, einfach alles leer, oh, oh, The Joe, so jetzt können wir erst mal
kurz hinlegen und mal kurz die Ammo wechseln, die Ammo ist zwar nicht die geilste dafür,
aber ich mein, irgendeine Ammo ist immer noch besser als keine Ammo, hauen wir mal hier
den Midi-Pack hin, falls wir den gleich brauchen, okay, gehen wir mal hier, gehen wir mal rein,
da geht es rein hier, oh ne, da ist ein Panzer, ist zwar nicht so gut rein, kommt ein Hovercraft,
oh was ist denn hier los, ach das ist noch, das Hovercraft ist übrigens auch so geil
verbackt, dass du erst mal zwei Leute siehst und dann feststellst, ach nein, ist doch ein,
oh da ist was, ist doch ein Hovercraft, keine Ahnung wo hier was ist, ich höre die Gegner
rumschreien, okay, das ist ja wie Metro 2033 mit der Ammo, ja, rare, richtig rare Ammo,
okay, hier rettet mich keiner, ich bin ja sonst wo, ach guck mal, die haben, wir nehmen jetzt
aber wieder ein, exquisite, ich hoffe ich schalte gleich mal ein paar gescheite Magazine für
die Waffe frei, 21 ist einfach viel zu wenig bei der Schussgeschwindigkeit, da nehme ich
sogar lieber ein bisschen weniger Damage in Kauf, anstatt dass ich hier so mit quasi
nichts an Schuss rumlaufe, der ist doch bestimmt hier auf dem Dach, oder, der ist doch bestimmt,
das ist, Moment, Moment, ich muss auf die Anti-Dingskornade, auf hier hinterher, next,
okay, der liegt einfach mitten in der Base, da musst du jetzt auch dreist, das sollte
eigentlich fast schon illegal sein, übrigens nächste Woche Freitag wird das Hovercraft
gepatcht, angeblich, wenn sie sich an ihren eigenen Patch, Patch, Stand halten, wenn
sie sich an ihren eigenen Patch stand halten, ist nächste Woche, nächste Woche vorbei,
mit Hover, Hallo, Game, Game, dann ist vorbei, mit Hovergecrafted, Post-Jump, mal gucken,
ich bin ja gespannt, die haben ja eh schon nicht so die Wahnsinns-Patches angekündigt
bisher, und ich bin ja mal gespannt, ob sie sich wenigstens an ihre eigenen Patch, also
an ihre eigene Patch, Roadmap, heißt das glaube ich, halten, oh, oh, oh, einfach mal
voll vorbei gefetzt, kein mega Killstreak mehr vom Dach, wir könnten eigentlich mal
hier Webster an Start bringen, Drive-By, hätte ja auch fast funktioniert, oh, jetzt müssen
wir aber, jetzt müssen wir aber rein hier, jetzt müssen wir aber rein, jetzt müssen
wir aber rein, Alpha 1 lost, schlecht, mag, ich mag das nicht, wenn man, wenn man, eh,
wo du hinguckst, ja, aber immerhin unser Squad owned, verhältnismäßig 5, also Top 5 Squad
bin ich eigentlich immer zufrieden, Top 5 Squad, da kann man sich immer sagen, ok, man
ist, man ist vielleicht nicht der Allergeilste, Heli-Basher oder so, aber man hat, man hat
immerhin, hat nix was gerissen, ich hoffe ja, wir können hier noch rein, ich mein, die
sind zum, oh hier komm, rein da, rein da, bashen, alter, bashen, ein paar Leute killen,
oh hier, richtig nice, richtig nice, im Container, Nosher Cannons, alter, alter, ich wollte, ok,
das kannst du nicht machen, hier ist nix, hier geht nix, das ist übrigens auch das,
was ich meinte in meinem Video mit Breakthrough, es tummeln sich gerade an dieser Flagge, es
ist ja nur eine Flagge, also es ist ein bisschen, ich hab nur 1080Ti, es ist ein bisschen zu
vergleichen, Battlefield 3, 4, 1, 5, man hat ja, ach, ich bleib hier drinnen, man hat
jetzt quasi 128 Spieler konzentriert an einer Flagge, deswegen sag ich halt auch, dass Breakthrough
halt, obviel ist, dass der da stand, oder, hätt man ja mal mit rechnen können, jetzt
hast du halt richtig krassen Clusterfuck hier, weil jetzt 128 Spieler quasi so in dem Gebiet,
in dem Gebiet unterwegs sind, was früher so 16 vs. 16 war oder sowas, oh, da ist er
in die Luft geflogen, Spawns sind nicht bronken, das, ich glaub noch nicht mal, dass die Spawns
so wirklich bronken sind, also es wirkt jetzt so, die Sache ist nur die, wo willst du dich
machen, wir sind halt in dem Gebiet von einer normalen Map, also von einer normalen Battlefield
4 Map, jetzt auf einmal, 108 zu einen Spieler, oh, da sag ich, egal wo du hinläufst, und
ich glaub wir wurden noch nicht einmal von vorne, von vorne gekillt diese Runde, ah,
Granate, bam, schreckt, ich hab Schiss vorzugehen, wenn ich jetzt vorgehe, krieg ich bestimmt
auf den Sack, Motion Sensor, ey, okay, ey, das Medipack müsste halt viel schneller sein,
wir können uns auch einen Ranger droppen, wir droppen uns einfach einen Ranger hierhin,
easy Ranger Drop, Alter, was ist hier los, was ist hier los, Mann, Keg W, ich kann ja
nur noch liegen, ich kann ja nicht mehr aufstehen, so, noch ein Motion Sensor, bisschen XP machen
muss immer sein, so, mein Ranger ist auch am Start, okay, ach, wir haben es, easy, Battlefield
4 Maps sind kleiner, ja, die Sache ist halt die, hier an der Stelle, bei diesen zwei Flaggen,
das ist halt nur ein Bruchteil der Map, der ungefähr so groß ist wie eine Battlefield
3 oder Battlefield 4 Map, und in der Zone tummelt es sich jetzt an 128, das ist einfach
zu krasser Clusterfuck, ja, das ist auch mein persönlicher Topfix für dieses Spiel, was
man macht, ach ja, ich lade dich wieder ein, klar, mein persönlicher Topfix für das Spiel,
was man machen könnte, relativ easy, man könnte sagen, hey, wir nehmen die Maps, die
wir jetzt haben, machen einfach aus jeder Map 1 bis 3 64-Mann-Gebiete draus, dann müsstest
du quasi kaum Inhalte machen, außer neue Map-Zonen setzen, und du könntest zumindest
sowas wie Breakthrough oder Leute, die es halt nicht so Clusterfuckig bevorzugen, relativ
einfach abfrühstücken, Daily-Streamer, ich bin vor allem gerade Daily-Urlauber, bis Januar,
das kommt ja noch dabei, du hast Recht, es sind nicht nur 128 Spieler, es ist auch noch
Maps, die keine Deckung haben, genau, das ist ja die Kombination, klar, natürlich, so,
sind wir jetzt alle wieder da, jupp, das ist klar, das ist die Kombination, ich gehe davon
aus, dass 128 Spieler mit den wirklich gut durchdachten Maps leicht funktionieren könnten,
nee, keine Ahnung, wann es in Portal wieder was gibt, also ich bin der Ansicht, also entweder
ein Server-Browser für All-Out-Warfare oder mindestens, und da haben sie sich leider sehr
bedeckt, mindestens eine Map-Selection, weil ganz im Ernst, ich will, Moment, wir haben
hier vier Maps, hier haben wir doch, hier haben wir doch die Maps, die Maps, weil ganz
im Ernst, ich möchte eigentlich nicht Hourglass spielen, ich möchte nicht Discarded spielen,
und ich möchte nicht Breakaway spielen, also auf jeden Fall Breakaway und Hourglass schon
mal auf gar keinen Fall, und einfach eine Map-Selection, dass man zumindest seine Hass-Maps
gar nicht gezwungen wird zu spielen, ansonsten musst du ja quasi laufend raus, wenn du keinen
Bock auf die Maps hast und so, ach, wir sind wieder Defense, ich mag eigentlich Defense,
nicht so gern, er ist gerade in Breakthrough, strich Spoggers als Attack, ja, gehen wir
hier bei unseren Team-Mats, jetzt könnt ihr mal richtig Clusterfuck sehen, jetzt könnt
ihr genau das sehen, was ich meine, mit, es tummeln sich jetzt 128 Spiele auf einem Gebiet,
wo sich früher 32 oder 64 getummelt haben, ist der Webster OP, ja und nein, Webster ist
der beste Specialist Mobility-wise, und ich würde auch immer noch sagen, eigentlich für
Leute, die auf so was stehen, der beste Specialist, das Problem ist, dass die Maps leider zu wenig
hergeben, guckt mal, hier, guckt euch an, Spoggers Clusterfuck, er ist noch drauf, Tür braucht
da eh kein Mensch, er braucht die Tür, Motion Sensor in die Richtung knallen und dann nix
wie weg, so Motion Sensor dahin, Motion Sensor hierhin und jetzt, piss dich, Alde, nix wie
weg, aber ich hab immer noch das Mini-Pack, das ist dumm, oh, oh, ach, schau mal gut, noch
mal ein Motion Sensor dahin, ne, ne, ne, ne, Kollegen, so nicht, oh, der Captain Peng
guckt euch an, ich denk permanent ich werd gehittert, was ich gar nicht werde, das ist
irgendwie komisch, das ist dieses komische Löschding an der Decke, guckt euch den Clusterfuck
an, I can't wait, man, I can't wait, okay, oh, oh, oh, wow, vielleicht, oh, der sitzt
in der, der macht das richtig, so muss das machen, vielleicht krieg ich nen Rest, das
wär schon, das wär Massive Pork, nice, THX, hier, da vorne muss die Granate rein, die
geht, die geht steil, noch ein Motion Sensor hin, wir müssen ja wissen, was da abgeht,
ich bin der einzige, der grad am Start ist, okay, ich versuch mal diese Seite zu halten
hier, Mini-Pack auf die Füße, was willst du machen, du kannst nicht mehr raus, Motion
Sensor auffüllen, es ist kein, ist kein Ammo Box mehr da, okay, vielleicht, vielleicht
können wir hinten raus, vielleicht können wir hinten raus, ich hab nämlich ehrlich gesagt
kein Nerv, das 500 Tickets lang in diesem Haus zu stehen, Smoke, nice, Smoke, Smoke ist
immer gut, Box Smoke, hier ist gar nix mehr, alle schon down, oh, Hovercraft, Hovercraft,
das ist so ein Upfuck, ein Clusterfuck, guckt's euch an, du hockst immer im Bunker, also
ich halt ja auch mal ganz gern irgendwelche Close Quarters Dinger, aber insgesamt muss
man sagen, so auf die ganze Runde muss das jetzt auch nicht sein, ach guck mal, ich glaub
wir gehen auch mal hinten raus und checken das ab, Bunkerstells, der Angriff A1 ist nicht
erfolgt, noch nicht, der Angriff A1 wird das wieder in Ordnung bringen, oh, oh nix wie
weg, ich dachte die Granate kommt gut, aber kam sie nicht, oh was ein Clusterfuck, der
Raum ist so lieb, alles klar, nice, danke, Panzmann, ja, das liegt aber unter anderem
auch an Low-Settings von mir, aber nicht nur, ne also natürlich müssen die auch dafür
sorgen, dass das Spiel mit Low-Settings irgendwie halbwegs brauchbar aussieht, schon klar, aber
Motion Sensor, Motion Sensor, oh, wir müssen auf der anderen Seite raus und dann mal ein
bisschen reinhalten, wenn wir nicht, ey alter, sag mal, du kannst hier nicht mal, da machst
du nix, ok, wisst ihr was, ich geh wieder, ich geh wieder, ich geh wieder, ich geh jetzt
aufs Dach, so, ich geh jetzt aufs Dach, jetzt vorbei, ich geh aufs Dach, ich hau ab, ich
geh jetzt weg, ich geh aufs Dach, man kann nicht aufs Dach, jetzt lass mich rein, ich
will aufs Dach, so tschüss, tschüss, ich geh jetzt, bye bye, bye bye, ah yes, ist ja
pure Erholung hier, gleich kommen ein paar Helis, ah Bug, Bug, hat aber gut mit der Minimap
zusammengepasst, probieren wir mal, probieren wir mal, ne, das war zu hoch, Achtung, wir
versuchen jetzt ein paar Sniper zu bashen, wir versuchen mal ein paar Sniper zu bashen,
mal gucken, ob das, ok, wir machen einmal ne Ehrenrunde ums Haus und hoffen, dass wir,
dass wir irgendwie paar Sniper erwischen, ist alles voll, oh Leute, Leute, Leute, ich
sags euch, wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen, what the hell, was soll ich denn, gut, dass
das alles so gut funktioniert, gut, dass das alles so gut, ah ok, sehr gut, sehr gut, nice,
nice spawn game, TH, bist am Start, nice, gar nicht gesehen hast du da, ich hab nur gesehen,
dass einer dir geantwortet hat, ah ok, das hat den nicht gekillt, ey, du kannst hier
nicht spielen, das geht nicht, das ist unmöglich, es ist absolut unmöglich man, gibt es einen
Patch, ähm, nö, dazu kann ich, dazu kann ich nur sagen, es gibt kein, also heute hat
kein Patch irgendwas gefixt, also nein, der Day 2 Patch hat nicht alles gefixt, darf
ich jetzt vielleicht wieder in dieses komische Haus rein, was hat man sich dabei gedacht,
wer hat gedacht, das lässt sich gut spielen, ey, ok, vielleicht darf ich mal meinen Team
halt rein spawnen, der irgendwie ins Haus reinkommt noch, nice, lass mich rein, lass mich rein,
ich theatre, ich demERGAH THAT, weather2.cor, wo sind wir hier, lass du BASHen, ach ok, immerhin,
immerhin immerhin im kreis gefahren paar leute gekillt man spawn richtig open field ja ach ja
guck mal da was ist hier los nein nein nein zehn sekunden man das wird nix dann verlieren wir das
jetzt gleich nice sehr gut sehr schön sehr schön und hier ist wieder clusterfuck angesagt gleich
ich sag's euch wo soll ich denn ich spiele jetzt gleich irgendwie ich spiele jetzt gleich den
sniper dude leg mich anrand der map und fliegt das ganze game nur mit meiner drone rum da mache
ich mehr xp als das spiel wirklich zu spielen und ich sterbe nicht instant laufend an irgendwelchen
dingern die ich nicht mal erkenne da ist bestimmt keiner heli stellts jawoll beste achtung achtung
auf poggers nate poggers nate poggers nate alter überall ist was du hast eine richtig
gute posi aber dann kriegste wisse gachi gachi bast in die seite chat sagt die squad namen sind
hat auch mit extra edge ausgesucht wie ist überhaupt unser squad night stalker ja ok das
ist wirklich cringe guck mal ein wetter effekt den man gebraucht hat dass man das spiel gut
bewerben kann ja wenn wir schon mal sand ins sind gehen wir da jetzt auch rein fliegen mal
eine runde auf auf die wetter dinger sind übrigens mittlerweile somit das unbedeutendste
eigentlich sollte ich jetzt abheben aber game alter wenn auch immer das wetter funktioniert
ich sehe nix dass du ei wackelt ja richtig nice effekt da wurde bestimmt monatelang
drüber drüber philosophiert wie man das ui am besten wackeln lassen kann sache ist jetzt
die wo wo sollen wir überhaupt hin achtung achtung den tut der tut der muss jetzt dran
glauben da kommt ein auto ich hau da jetzt einfach netz rein in der hoffnung springt
einer rein nice armor break sehr schön bringt mir halt nix abgelb mit der ppega 29 ui wackeln
kann man ausschalten ist nicht dass mich das großartig stellen würde ganz ehrlich das
ui wackeln ist glaube ich das kleinste problem was ich mit dem game habe oder fliegt einer
mit ganz schön im zigzag rum hier zigzag stills all occupied in combat all occupied der timer
war in der beta auch niedriger was ich persönlich ganz gut fand kann man hier was haben wir
am start ok was ich ich check jetzt geht jetzt einfach raus wo game jeff bezos auf den weg
ins weltall das funktioniert alles richtig gut kein falt mehr ich kann immer das gleiche
spielen doch hier müssen wir geben a 2 rein ausgezeichnet exzellent sozusagen exquisite
battlefield game das ist nur für five hat leute also wenn die genialität nicht erkennt
ist einfach nicht intelligent genug und ihr wisst ja ihr wisst ja jeder prime sub steigert
den iq für alle um eins exciting only in battlefield moments huge exciting helfe helfe boris boris
kommet helft mir boris angelo jawoll puki mvp oder wie man heutzutage sagt richtiger
ehrenmann puki falls man das noch sagt so guckt euch mal meine nice anti antifahrzeug
anti air nade ein der tropf flares der tropf immer flares weil die immer flares tropfen
tropft er keine flares oder kommt ein panzer sehr schön und da kommt ein auto oh guck mal
den gegner direkt vor mir und ich sterbe jetzt gleich weil ich keine ahnung habe wo hier
was abgeht ich schmerz ich werfe ein paar motion sensoren paar motions ja sehr gut
oh guck mal wenn ich gerät nee ich werde getebackt hat er mich gerade getebackt nee ich glaube
der will mich versuchen zu ressen und es funktioniert nicht ach das ist gar kein oh gott das game
ist so broken jawoll auf granate gib ihm gib ihm jawoll das war ich nicht aber sah so aus
als wäre ich das gewesen ich sage ich habe den heli gekillt ich habe zauber craft gekillt
in meiner granate habe ich so auch noch nicht gesehen wenigstens also du brauchst wirklich
krass harte nerven dafür ich meine das ist ja auch immer wieder an offenheit kaum zu
überbieten wisst ihr was wir gehen wir gehen jetzt einfach außen rum geht ja nicht anders
ich mache jetzt anti erstellt gegen den heli wenn ich ihn wieder sehe hier da ist er die
locken übrigens über die halbe map wie ihr seht also das geht auf den heli da hinten
jetzt die meine granaten obwohl die obwohl die sonst wo hingegangen sind vielleicht sind
die hier drinnen dachte vielleicht sind die hier drin weil motion sensor hier ist ja viel
deckung seht ihr die deckung chat also hier ist deckung guckt was sagt er sagen die immer
in dem spiel gibt es keine deckung ist ja obviously falsch sehr viel deckung sogar
borgers bei dir lief es doch gestern eigentlich ganz gut die mp9 ist meine eigentlich meine
lieblingswaffe jetzt schon nach ein paar stunden oder ja nach so lang aber das macht bock ich
mag so smg waffen die einfach die einfach close range viel damage machen haben wir
irgendwie eine chance hier irgendwas sinnvolles zu machen oder ich bin im panzer und bin gleich
bin ich gleich dauer ich verpiss mich ich hau ab wenn du deckung haben will spielen specialist
dafür genau weil dieses weil dieses schild ist jetzt erstmal so richtig das reißt raus
das schild hier achtung motion sensor volle polle ok wir versuchen nochmal fort zu pushen
da ist gut 20 schuss beste next vielleicht habe ich glück darf noch mal auf den schießen
ok ich habe auf ihm noch mal geschaut immerhin ich werde im kurd am besten von allen snipern
angeleuchtet permanent werfen wir werfen einfach noch ein bisschen anti er hier da der da auf
den da genau auf den sollst du locken geben wir fliegen die hin ok sollten die flares
nicht meine granate eigentlich ablenken rein rein von von der theorie sollte das glaube
ich so sein aber natürlich easy win easy easiest game wer hat sich eigentlich gedacht dass
eine anti antifahrzeug homing grenade so eine geile idee ist das specialist hat ja schon
zu wenig ich mein der hat wingsuit der hat extra granate der braucht jetzt noch 200
die emp granate ist übrigens gar nicht mal so übel meinst du es kommt in einem monat
im seel kann durchaus sein danke watch out nils danke für den sab kann durchaus sein
dass es im monat im seel kommt ich meine das game kommt ja nicht gerade gut weg und war
war battlefield 5 nicht auch nach irgendwie einem monat im seel warum anlocken ich sniper
dinger den spiele ich doch überhaupt nicht das war bf5 mein ich ja bfb 5 meine ich ja
war das nicht war das dann ich auch so dass die im seel waren direkt ja für alle die
mitgekriegt das ist witzig bf6 ahead of schedule haben sie noch anfang des ups bf6 ja a says
bf6 ist way ahead of schedule gut more players than ever before ist richtig aber wenn also
wenn dieses spiel way ahead of schedule ist dann frage ich mich ob das so gutes gutes
oh nein komm on nicht breakaway nicht breakaway da müssen wir das andere spiel nicht so groß
sind wir vielleicht sind wir attacker wenn wir attacker sind wobei die map ist eigentlich
egal egal was du spielst ist die map eigentlich ppega
schauen wir mal schauen wir mal was wir sind es ist eigentlich immer ppega
ihr habt jetzt genug posiert auf lasst die runde starten wir brauchen dann kopiope mode
ich glaube das hilft alles bei dem gam nicht mehr sie sind ja schon wieder defender dürfen
wir irgendwann auch mal attacken gut wir haben es bisher immer gut gehalten aber hier ist
so große range da sollte ich ppega 29 komm komm on easy wenn sonst wenn sonst nix geht
das geht immer ach medi create service erinnerungs dankeschön dankeschön ich darf leider nicht
mehr despawn das ist nicht erlaubt aber was ich machen kann nachdem nein ach geht das
jetzt nicht mehr alter game komm on nein ich möchte ich können nachdem wir defender sind
und haben unendlich tickets ich kann einfach re-spawn midi-pen hups kratsch das war das
spawn wie midi-pen geht aber schnell guck mal 5 hovercrafts direkt am start lange lax
dran auf gehts was unnubli so vielleicht haben diesmal klug ein paar gegner zu sehen ach
ja ich sehe ich sehe ein paar nicht viele nur so 80 ungefähr 80 gegner jetzt mal reicht
ok jetzt jetzt ist ppega time angesagt oh gott nice ich muss weg da sind total viele
hier oh fuck fuck scatter falls irgendjemand overwatch gespielt hat
handjoe handjoe jetzt jetzt verliert er die letzten gehirnzellen kratzer max handjoe habt
ihr handjoe gemeint in overwatch irgendwelche handjoe mains da handjoe mains any any handjoe
mains oh nein ppega 29 ist leer ok alles klar da mal sind spots sind das spots
spiele ich gegen bots gleich nuke leute gleich nuke die mau ab da isse oh boris boris lasst
mich in ruhe boris da ist die mau ab da ist die mau ab leute
die mau ab ich hab keinen heal das war ein problem die mau ab einfach mal 20 kills gemacht
einfach mal 20 kills das müsst ihr klippen leute da ging es ab hat es geklatscht ppega
29 am start ja man kann schon was reißen mit guter posi wobei die gegner das war jetzt
halt einfach also wenn man jetzt denkt es kommt das kommt immer so in dem gelben das
war jetzt quasi einmal alle drei stunden dass du sowas hast mal gucken ob wir unseren wingsuit
verwenden können wingsuit was war das ok achtung wingsuit wir fliegen wir meinen flieger
steils die fliege steils massive massive fly wobei ich glaube da vorne ist gar nicht
mal gar nicht mal so gut da ist da ist links und rechts alles voller gegner ich brauch
die andere net hier dankeschön ne ne das sogar richtig dumm ehrlich gesagt vielleicht
aber vielleicht kann ich hier wieder runter fliegen seck das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren
vielleicht vielleicht kann ich mit meinem wingsuit vielleicht kann ich mit meinem wingsuit
wenn mich das game lässt recht als dank der game game nice game das mich am leben please
motion sensor hier sind meine güte weg ppega werden sie jetzt gleich bett auch schon spät
heute ist schon spät kann es sein schon spät ich bin noch bis 23 ich bin ich bin 23 aber
gut dass wir ppega 29 spielen mit der mp9 hätte ich gar nicht so viel killen können
weil die mp9 zu wenig schuss hat ein motion sensor hin hin feuern
oh nee jetzt ist ppega 29 leer oh ist schlecht da machst du nix da machst du nix ppega fiesta
ja hast echt nix gerade holst du easy ja sind ja nur 20 leute in dem gebäude drin ich hätte
glaube ich vor ein paar nades droppen sollen auf die dann hätten sie sich nicht so auf
mich hier liege stellts fliege stellts vielleicht ja ich darf ja nicht oh nice ich werde gerätst
poc team mates of the year
alle können euch einfach hinlegen und mich schätzen es überhaupt kein problem das sind
doch keine gegner die haben die sind die sind blau am gürtel wenn die blau am gürtel sind
außerdem sind wir hier und die gegner da ne ne ne das sind keine hier sind keine gegner
ach guck mal da heli stellts spotten ich weiß gar nicht wo ich hinfliegen soll vielleicht
hier oh nee das ist so blöde super machst du nix halt helfen sie mir kennt ihr dieses
polizei meme oder dieses dieses how to selbstverteidigungs stop halt helfen sie mir hallo hier helf
sie mir hier bitte helfen sie mir das also ich kann mir richtig vorstellen wie gut einem
das in frankfurt am bahnhof helfen hilft ach jetzt kommt die ganz kurze zipline guck mal
also wenn man sowas bauen muss dass eine map architektur funktioniert hätte man sich vielleicht
überlegen kann so ich weiß nicht vielleicht ist es doch nicht so die geile idee ich will
eigentlich nur hier hoch dass ich fliegen kann ich will dann da hinten zu dem anderen
punkt da stellten sie bestimmt zuerst runter verkämpft mich an b2 gleich wo sind sie denn
ach ja erkennt er wer wir auf der map sind wo sind wir auf der map chat gibt 500 gamers
kommen hier erkennt wo wir sind man kann nicht rein so wo sind wir ich habe keine ahnung
wo wir sind ok man kommt noch mehr geflogen ist spielbar geworden mit dem patch oh ja
der day 2 patch meinst du ja der day 2 patch hat nicht gefixt man Mensch dieses game immer
von der seite irgendwas weg ppega hat game hört auf auf mich zu schießen man da kommt
was ah ne das war meiner ok ppega 29 for the win ich spiele einfach nichts anderes mehr
warum soll ich was anderes spielen hier motion sensor fang fang noch mehr motion sensor vielleicht
jetzt mal hier da kommen sie schon da kommen sie schon kommen sie schon ok ich könnte
schwören die ersten schüsse haben nicht gehitted kannst du runde mitspielen theoretisch schon
ich guck mal ob noch einer ist von den leuten nicht in der liste hab vielleicht wieder erx
wenn nicht klar warum nicht ein platz haben wir noch frei gab es wieder ein patch nö es
gab kein patch also nein der hat auch nichts gefixt sehr geil bin ganz meiner deiner meinung
es sind viele die ich den ich da wohl relativ aus der aus der seele gesprochen habe darf
ich von hier starten vielleicht oh was denn das es ist einfach nur da um da zu sein es
hat keinen tieferen sinn keck hallo game warum darf ich von hier nicht lauschen ist es nicht
hoch genug nein es geht nicht da bin ich darf darf nicht lauschen davon kein wingsuit für
dich vielleicht hier eine darf ich nicht hoch ok dazu schießen war blöd jetzt wissen die
dass wir da sind wo sind wir überhaupt ok es ist ja mal sagt der chat ist ja das geilste
game ever das ganze vor allem im vergleich zu anderen schon so krass intuitiv omega lul
es ist auch geil dass sie hier mit arktik stels rumlaufen auf der schnee map das ist
eigentlich big brain das soll ich auch machen ok da gehe ich nicht hin da fahren 5 vorwärts
rum drei panzer und sind 20 gegner spawnen
ja warum schreien die immer so rum die du es monka ich hole dich ok sorry leute fürs
rumgeschrei das war ein bisschen zu viel ich habe nur da links geguckt da sind einfach
zwanzig gegner wieder weißt du eingekillt clear ich habe die sind da gesporn ich wette
leute ich wette um die installation von wettkrieg 2042 die sind da gesporned bei irgendeinem
weil ich habe keine schritte gehört null und auf einen schlag höre ich zehn gegner
neben mir laufen oder aber was auch möglich wäre die sound engine ist im arsch gewesen
könnte auch sein es auch möglich glaube wir switchen gleich auf webster das hier ein
bisschen oben rumstelzen kann oder kommt was das ist auch straight straight durchgegangen
macht das scheiß den kaputt beim next please machst kaputt einer neben mir kommt er von
oben oder steht er hier um die eck die stehen hier um die ecke oder stehen die obendrauf
ja klar ich habe mir da einen ab und der macht einfach nur in kopf und ich werde gerätzt
oder nicht nop boris boris gekommret okay nein dachte mir boris dachte sein netter boris
die anderen boris die ich heute gesehen habe die war nicht so nett aber es gibt ja zum
glück genug borise was ist denn die mehrzahl von boris boris boris borises vielleicht vielleicht
kennt sich da jemand mit aus muss man ja hier wissen weil hier gibt es ja alles fünffach
bohren bohren das ist eine gute idee ein boris mehrere bohren das finde ich nicht schlecht
ja das passt so wir switchen mal kurz hier gibt es nicht mehr so viel zu fliegen jetzt
borises vielleicht jetzt kommen wir probieren mal mit der mp9 aus webstore für dachstells
also 37 21 das lässt sich sehen warum labern die eigentlich so viel die boros boros ja
vorgurts warum labern die specialist eigentlich die ganze zeit irgendwas macht man macht man
das im kriech so weil das ist ja das ist ja fast wie in echt hier offensichtlich
da ist ein hovercraft der einfach jetzt mich gleich best den müssen wir im auge behalten
da tropfen sie gleich raus hier tropfen gleich raus und guckt euch die schneiber dudes an
das meine ich meck webster ist der beste specialist das problem ist warum es nicht wirklich ist
die maps geben es halt nicht richtig her wir haben der mp9 aber die mp9 ist auf die range
richtig mies richtig mies guckt euch das an ok wir machen jetzt ok das war schlecht
ist webster eigentlich nur für premiumkäufer nö aber webster ist auf level 15 das muss
man erst freispielen jetzt hast du jetzt haben wir mal eine gute aktion gemacht und gleich
wieder von der seite weg pepega ok leute ihr seht schon mp9 geht hier grad nix rein pepega
29 ist wieder angesagt ok ich habe das jetzt hier ab was soll ich sonst machen ok vielleicht
vielleicht vielleicht alter dieses spiel es macht mich so fertig egal wo du ja schon
spät leute ich weiß egal wo es ist immer irgendwie fünf für einen den du siehst sehen
ich fünf es wäre krass feifert gewesen leute mit premium nur heroes ja das hat ja gut funktioniert
jetzt bin ich komplett useless weil ich nicht rüber komm ok geht wieder ok pepega 29 vom
dach jetzt so motion sensor rüber und jetzt tepse weg geben wir mal hier in zicht noch
mal motion sensor rüber gekloppt irgendwas hat mich geht es auch wir haben 500 xp gekriegt
weil wir pogger squad sind habt das gesehen nur das pogger squad bekommt 500 bonus xp
wir haben ja auch capn poggers bei uns mit dabei da kann eigentlich nichts mehr schief
gehen oder man könnte auch fast sagen einmal poggers immer poggers hallo game wollte ich
sagen ich war da nicht drauf oder was nein nein heli du nicht heli heli heli heli lass
mich in ruhe motion sensor da drüben wieder hin ok ich habe keine ahnung warum da nichts
hätte aber wahrscheinlich das würde ich schon nicht mal dem dem game zu schreiben
wahrscheinlich schieße ich auf punkte die eigentlich gar nicht da drin sind die nur
so aussehen als ob ein kill ich fasse es nicht den autodude rausschießen hier was haben
wir mal ausprobieren können ist ich wollte sagen wir können uns versuchen rüber zu schwingen
das ist ein guter winkel das ist eigentlich ein ganz guter winkel muss ich sagen ist ja
gut gekillt wird ja nichts weiß man die tickrate vom server ne aber die ist auch die ist aber
auch ziemlich unbedeutend die tickrate vom server gerade das game hat so krasse lags
teilweise und ruckeln rum da wird es jetzt die bessere tickrate auch nicht helfen bin
stark leute ich bin ich war stark ich korrigiere ich war stark darf nicht springen so jetzt
müssen wir mal aufpassen weil hier gleich gleich geht es ab gleich kriegen wir gleich
kann man hier oben drauf oder es wäre big brain alter massive sprain of my life hier
huge play huge play ok das war pepega im aber massive play war gleich noch mal es hat ja
funktionieren können naja fuck down six hat ne 46 die runde geht doch echt ganz gut rein
also alles über 40 kills gerade auf so großen maps finde ich ist dann schon wirklich eine
brauchbare runde lass mich rein hier muss aufs dach was ist sommer wie wäre es mit
die fänden jungs anstatt auf auf dach zu campen das dach camper wir fahren da jetzt
rein jetzt geht es rein hier jetzt geht es rein von der seite nacht misst ein bisschen
verämt in battle field 3 in battle field 4 werde es jetzt halt einfach so in so einem
pass was ich auf den 10er kill oder so raus gelaufen weil ich nicht von der seite direkt
einer weglatscht sechs drohende luft es sind nicht nur sechs drohen in der luft es sind
wahrscheinlich sechs hovercraft sechs helis sechs drohen sechs mal boris und alles alles
mindestens sechs mal unterwegs oder mehr aber wir könnten das hier eigentlich verteidigen
wenn wir es clever machen wenn wir es schlau machen man kann die rausschießen das problem
ist nur man muss ganz genau hitten dass das funktioniert was das hier so muss es sein
so muss es sein sehr gut sehr gut gucken was wir hier haben ok nice kein kill alles klar
ich das war blöd da hätte ich nicht kommitten sollen ich wusste wenn ich jetzt noch lange
da stehe bin ich dauernd aber da hat er halt aber gehabt wenn ich glück habe krieg ich
den rest ihr könntet mich ressen ihr könntet also das würde funktionieren ihr würdet
noch nicht mal sterben aber die sind ja doch von hinten i need help please i need help
da kommt die oma die oma kommt ja poggers beste beste oma
ok wir hauen aber motion sensor rein hier geht es gerade ab definitiv nicht mehr normal
ein bisschen bisschen konzentraten ich dachte man muss da na fuck ich dachte man muss da
links aufs fenster schießen dass man durchs hovercraft vielleicht ist es auch die hovercraft
panzerung oder weiß das einer wo muss ich hinschießen aufs hovercraft ich dachte immer
links aufs fenster aber vielleicht auch nicht oh nice a flank nice a flank moment hier motion
motion motion ich hole dich ingo ingo ich hole dich ingo rutscht sonst wohin oh nee ingo
kann nicht gerettet sein weil ingo revive bug hat auch auch sehr schön ingo kann man
nicht reviven oh fuck alter was da los ist habt ihr gesehen wie viel da drin ist da sind
60 leute in der lagerhalle oder so da mach ich nix was soll ich denn da jetzt machen
kann ich trotzdem von hinten noch mal rein stelzen oder so einfach noch mal aufs dach
oder sowas vielleicht vielleicht habe ich glück also ich meine die base ist die base
ist lost aber ok das war dumm jetzt wissen sie dass ich da bin hinten vielleicht ok ok
ok vielleicht kriege ich da doch noch ein bisschen was hier da kommt gleich was unter
mir gehen jetzt einfach rein und stelzen uns von der seite perfekt einfach alle killen
easy ich habe alle gekillt habt ihr gesehen sind alle gestorben inklusive mir was macht
was macht boris 570 eigentlich genau an seinem turret da oben da ist auch überhaupt nix
ach mensch game come on weg gachi bust von der seite gibt es mittlerweile xp in portal
soweit ich weiß nicht da hat da hat auch der da hat auch der day two patch leider nicht
geholfen kappa wo gehts denn hier lang ach ja in der standard playlist aber wenn ihr
euch die standard playlist von portal da playlist ist ja was ich also mich schocken die mich
schockt die standard playlist nicht und vor allem schockt mich die battlefield 3 und
battlefield bed company 2 implementierung von portal überhaupt gar nicht muss ich ehrlich
sagen oh fuck was geht denn hier hallo nein ich check nicht was hier abgeht wir gehen
jetzt einfach mal runter sag mal kann das sein game please mach doch einfach mal was
ich will ich dachte die liegen vielleicht da oben
noch oder auch nicht kann schon sein hier ist nix dachte vielleicht stellst du was ok
hier bin ich ein wenig zu export über mir über mir bpg 29 alter habt ihr gesehen was
da über mir gelaufen ist ich komme direkt vor den raus jetzt sind sie unter mir können
sie sich mal entscheiden ging ja noch raus ich weiß kann ich weiß so wirklich machen
so mit meinem mobility stells hier vielleicht da oben drauf mal runter gucken mein gott
game kann irgendwas funktionieren was eingebaut ist ich muss jetzt gerade mal ein bisschen
aufregend aber was ist das denn hier mein mensch funs halt einfach please wo ist ja
da unten da unten stellte die werden jetzt gebäscht durch den damit rechnet keiner
dass man hier oben motion sensor rein alter was ein was ein sport mann was ein sport
null ppega 29 sage ich dazu nur ppega 29 ich mache mal hier neues mit können wir noch
was trocken ich darf nichts trocken ich habe mit 56 43 eindeutig eindeutig zu wenig punkte
gemacht als dass ich mal was trocken darf wo ist das wo sind die ach da vorne
diese waffe na gut aber mal ehrlich gesagt mit dem assault rifle und der posey hätte
es auch funktioniert aber natürlich machts ppega 29 einfacher
ok die sind schon in die mitte gestellt alles klar sterben simulator 2.0 demnächst team
early access how to sterben auf einer platform oder was auch immer das darstellen soll das
was ist das ist es chat ist es eine platform ob schon das bestimmt platform und weg hallo
hinter eck die tür geht nicht
die wurden richtig gebäscht gerade die haben ja mal sowas von in den in den poppers
gekriegt hyper gatschi mann die kommers waren wir dazu helfte boris ich glaube boris ist
besonders beliebt bei leuten die frisch anfangen weil die denken sich der turret ist so geil
das sind die ganzen das sind die ganzen torbjörn spieler die ganzen torbjörn spieler die sagen
jetzt ha ha boris boris nice boris turrell ich spiel boris
dankeschön heli sehr gut ich hab jetzt urlaub ja korrekt zum glück hab ich jetzt urlaub
mit echt mit echt zeit da ist noch einer das hast du dir so gedacht das hast du dir so
gedacht ich glaube die runde lade ich hoch auf youtube ach nee kann ich ja nicht wenn
ich auf youtube was hoch lade aktuell und nicht das spiel wahrscheinlich total flamme
sagen alle das ist bestimmt sponsored von ea weil es eigentlich wirklich coole runde
wo man doch ich weiß ich wollte ja noch ich wollte ja noch ein video machen wer mehr werde
ich wahrscheinlich erstmal wirklich nicht machen wird man auch wieder zeit für für
stellen anzeigen video und sowas ich wollte ja noch video machen was man eventuell kurzfristig
machen könnte um das spiel zumindest erträglicher zu machen beziehungsweise auch ein bisschen
mehr klassische battlefield fans anzusprechen ist das noch also die einfachsten sachen die
man jetzt ohne großen aufwand machen könnte dass man das spiel zumindest noch den leuten
dies gekauft haben für 100 euro bisschen paar stunden spielspaß schenken kann denke das
könnte man relativ easy machen in dem man beispielsweise die großen maps aufsplittet
in eins bis drei areale und da wenigstens finden da 64 mann draus macht da musste nichts
neues für machen muss nur neue map grenzen ziehen und ich glaube da hätten auch leute
die eher so ein bisschen klassisches pp 29 jawohl bärbe bärbe bärbe bärbe bärbe
leute was war das für ein kill alter ich habe absichtlich nicht getappt ich habe ich spray
einfach mal wie der letzte vollhorst rein und es hat funktioniert hat funktioniert
als ob wir machen leute pfeiffer time passt mal auf messer pfeiffer park hier sind keine
gegner aber es war nice das muhen müsst ihr zugeben oder aber es hätte funktionieren
können es hätte es hätte klappen können aber aber sind keine gegner mehr da und jetzt
leute lehrtaste so was nervt mich immer so was geht mir richtig auf und sagt wenn das
nicht funktioniert obwohl es funktionieren müsste hast du nicht genau das ist leute
ich hab euch gebadet ich will das jetzt einfach nur auf das game schieben weil ich die nicht
gedrückt habe ja erwischt exposed richtig hart exposed exposed jetzt ist es max max
liegt revealed exposed alles in einem alter die schild tut es man die schild tut es guckt
zu euch an ok wir machen wieder 6 herr oh moment moment pp 29 nein pp 29 muss brauche magazin
wechsel 64 sogar hat nicht gereicht warum ist es so pro man
der der sound na der sound ist nicht stumpf der sound hat einfach schlicht ergreift aussetzer
und zeigt null an wo jemand ist wo ist der typ angeblich ist hier einer ich sehe den
nicht da oben irgendwo sagt bloß da oben stellt seiner näher umstellt keiner das kann
nicht sein übrigens die base ist mega schwer einzunehmen wenn man hier vielleicht sieht
ho ho monka hd monka ultra hd oh es war so gut gedacht leider hat es nicht in der ausführung
geklappt aber es ist also deswegen mag ich webster hey max ging mal was bei deiner arbeitskollegen
die dich bei das ist schon ewig her das war noch als ich beim provider gearbeitet habe
das ist zehn jahre her oder so aber nee ich habe die nach der ausbildung auch nicht wieder
gesehen also nie wieder pp gar 9 und 20 torbjörn turret ja zwar das war aber nicht nur der
torbjörn turret das war auch der typ selbst weil die habe ich leider nicht wieder gesehen
schade war das also nee jetzt habe ich sorry ich habe ich ich wusste ja nicht dass der
medic am start ist normalerweise gerät sorry also wusste ja nicht hier postschirm postschirm
gehen wir hier seitlich rein hinter uns hinter uns kommt hinter uns kommt einfach einer der
gerade habt ihr das gesehen das finde ich nice an bettel viel der hat uns gefleckt
von hinten und da kam unser hoffa kopf nach den aus versehen überfahren also wenn wir
jetzt nicht squad 1 den weiß ich auch nicht ich hatte an die 70 kills 50 assist pass mal
auf mal gucken was das game anzeigt jetzt am ende mal gucken was ich gemacht habe ach
hipfire kills ach ja klar ja klar also 70 70 kills und 50 assist das ist nicht der rede
wer zehn hipfire kills da ist es da ist es das ist das ist die wahre leistung gewesen
in der runde zehn hipfire kills und wisst ihr warum die die kills nicht anzeigen wisst
ihr warum bin wir da ziemlich sicher die wollen nicht dass andere leute sich schlecht fühlen
wobei ich damit überhaupt keine probleme hätte wenn ich gesagt habe dann weiß ich
das doch selbst ist dieses spiel besser als wenn gar das kann ich dir nicht sagen weil
ich wenn gar nicht gespielt habe das erste call of duty seit einer ganzen weile was ich
nicht gekauft habe aber ich kann dir sagen ich würde dir nicht empfehlen 2042 jetzt
zu kaufen alle da die patchen das kopium emote der patch nächste woche wird das spiel definitiv
besser machen wenn sie das hovercraft also wenn das hovercraft gepatcht wird macht das
spiel auf jeden fall besser und ob die spmm drin haben ich habe ich glaube ja immer noch
bisschen zumindest man man macht das nicht alles rein nicht alles raus und dann sowas
nicht einzubauen wenn gerade ist gerade kostenlos für alle paar tage oder ich muss mal ganz
schnell währends währends lädt ich sehe ich bin mal ganz schön auf dem klo
ich bin mal ganz schön auf dem klo
nein das stimmt nicht du kannst den portal nicht den normalen server browser benutzen
es gibt keine server in portal es gibt du kannst spiele hosten die aber automatisch
wieder zugehen es gibt keine persistente server oh clusterfuck kaleidoskop und ich habe sie
heute mal im video gesagt auch nicht schon wieder defender come on lass uns mal ein bisschen
attacken ich meine die map ist nicht zu verlieren als defender das kommt ja dabei aber die erste
base ist schon richtig ppeger ok wir wechseln die waffe habe ich jetzt einfach mal schnell
gekillt weil wir haben eh unendlich tickets jetzt wechseln wir mal schnell mp9 aber nicht
mckay wir spielen es anderen sehr gut kommt bestimmt noch das sauerhafte server also
alles was sie nicht angekündigt haben und wirklich verpflichtet sind ohne dass sie richtig
krasse flames klingen zu machen glaube ich machen sie nicht die sind die sind mit Sicherheit
genug mit dem game beschäftigt und das mietbare server kommen habe ich keine hoffnung mehr
ich meine ich würde mich freuen ja keine frage ich wäre echt happy wenn es mietbare
gibt aber oh fuck alter hier ist deckung leute ich habe deckung gefunden ich habe die deckung
entdeckt dachte nicht dass die gegner schon direkt direkt vor meiner nase sind wenn ich
da rauslaufe der stream leckt leckt das stream gerade also jetzt in game müsste es eigentlich
flüssig sein wie gesagt es leckt es leckt nur im nur im ladebildschirm im ladebildschirm
leckt immer da kann ich aber nichts für und ich weiß nicht woran es liegt das game macht
halt einfach 100 prozent 100 prozent cpu last im ladebildschirm weil da es sich gedacht
hat das ist so ein mega poggers game da kann man aber 100 prozent cpu für opfern oder
kommt was von hinten ich habe keine ahnung wo es abgeht also doch ich weiß wo es abgeht
aber es ist so viel dass ich nicht nicht nicht checke was alles abgeht ich weiß nur dass
ich meine meinen motion sensor als die tür raus werfe und gleich meine granate hinterher
schmeißen enemy spotted poggers so hier granate am start bm damage exzellent einfach einfach
mal fett damage gemacht schmeißen wir noch einen motion sensor aus und holen uns gleich
einen neuen motion sensor da ist ein hovercraft hinten da ist das geht so weg ok rausgehen
ist eine ganz schlechte idee gerade rausgehen möchte man gerade wirklich nicht warum krieg
ich denn hier damage was ist denn das raus oh achte ich dachte ich kann es ja mal probieren
das ist clusterfuck das ist übrigens genau das was ich meinte dass halt hier ich habe
meinen satz vergessen dass halt hier sich die sachen auf einer flagge klastern wie ansonsten
auf alten battlefield maps auf einer halt mit weniger spielern also mit mehr spielern
hier wirst ja in battlefields aber die das areal ist halt das gleiche das erinnert mich
hier an metro das erinnert mich hier ein bisschen bisschen an metro an der treppe da hast du
auch das spiel die ganze zeit dargestanden und eigentlich nur geradeaus geguckt und immer
mal wieder gegner gehittet nur dass metro schon clusterfuck hoch 10 war und das hier
einfach clusterfuck 2 hoch 128 ist und ich hoffe ich werde gerätzt wenn ich nicht gerätzt
werde dann komme ich nie wieder in das haus zurück oh wir werden überrannt ok hab nichts
gesagt wir werden gebashed eier was geben wir mit saranje kopf ab ist sehr gut das
bahn sehr gut exquisite dazu kann ich nur sagen next level shit ist eigentlich metro im portal
nein ok es ist doch ein bisschen zu viel range wir spielen jetzt mal was was machen wir kommen
hier wie ist eigentlich die ac die haben wir gerade anlockt wie ist die eigentlich ich
habe im hinterkopf das ist eine burstwaffe ja und burstwaffen ihr wisst ja also burstwaffen
ist so ein ding immer oh nee das ist nix für meinen ppega aim motion sensor
bekommen sie flamet auf französisch hab das gehört seit irgendwas auf französisch gesagt
ich kann kein französisch oh nee das ist nix für mich das ist zu das ist zu anstrengend
da muss man richtig teppfeiern und und ach natürlich was sonst da muss man richtig teppfeiern
aim und sich mühe geben ne das will ich nicht spielen sowas das ist nicht schon so anstrengend
wenn ich jetzt auch eine waffe habe die zusätzlich anstrengend ist nee nee das wird gleich wieder
ausgewechselt zu irgendwas anderem ob da was
zum was ist hier gerade los was ist hier gerade los ok reload vielleicht kriege ich komm
ein kill damit können wir doch machen andere seite vielleicht die rum stellsten ah nee
ich kann die mix aus dem auto hinten aber nicht mal das ok komm an hier oh gott burstwaffe
ok wir haben ein kill das reicht und schüss nächste ppega 29 wo kommen wir denn da hin
weil man sich für die waffe noch anstrengen muss nee nee das gibt es nicht hier wo krasse
revolution es gibt ein paar kleine revolution zum beispiel kann hier auf irgendeinem hochhaus
glaube ich der mast umfallen oder sowas glaube ich dass das hier auf der map war ich bin
mir gar nicht so sicher auf welcher map das gewesen ist ok game ja game lass mich doch
mal auswählen da genau da ist er das schneidermann habt ihr gesehen wie lang der gebraucht hat
überhaupt um auf mich zu zielen ich hab ich hab da zehn sekunden rumgelegen so spawnen
wir mal rein wieder vielleicht da hinten war er irgendwo das schneidermann vielleicht
ist er noch da ok captain poggers ich retz dich oh nee ich werd ich sehs schon ich werd
weg geaimt von der anderen seite oh dieser punkt dieses der punkt ist so ppega alter
jetzt hat man sich dabei gedacht einfach mal einfach mal auf ne wiese in mcom gesetzt
glaubst du dass es via patch noch einen server browser nachträglich geben wird ich glaube
nicht ich habe aber sag mal so ich könnte mir vorstellen dass man vielleicht map selection
macht dass man maps auswählen kann also zumindest vielleicht ein paar maps abwählen kann das
wäre das wäre wirklich nice ansonsten also ganz ehrlich wenn da nicht noch bald was
kommt sowohl an spielmodi als auch irgendwie an customized möglichkeiten für map selection
dann werde ich nicht lange spielen also werde ich wahrscheinlich auch so nicht aber weil
aktuell sieben maps wovon ich zwei absolut hasse und eine map nur richtig gut finde und
dass das ganze zwei spielmodi gibt also nee alter fliegt es einfach alles komplett durch
gerade ok ok aber captain poggers geht ab bin ich ja froh letzte runde ging ordentlich
was rein jetzt nicht aber das macht nix wir können die map nicht verlieren es ist unmöglich
es ist unmöglich eine ist breakaway korrekt breakaway und ist das habe ich vergessen wie
sie heißt breakaway leute ihr wisst doch was meine hasse maps sind heck wait alter ich
bin so ppega ich weiß nicht mal was meine hasse maps sind breakaway und hour class nee
nee kaleidoskop ist hier ja kaleidoskop ist dumm aber kaleidoskop an sich ist schon in
ordnung auch kommen hovercraft haben wir noch gar nicht gesehen heute schmeißen wir schmeißen
einfach mal ein paar granaten drauf in hoffnung das gilt was alles kann ich gerade machen
alter das game also das karten mag ich nicht so renewal ist gut gerade in breakthrough ist
renewal richtig richtig nice also ich finde ich finde renewal ist die beste die beste
breakthrough map das heißt das heißt schon was ja game ich würde mich gerne hinlegen
ich habe richtig kaste meist ok jetzt kommt die kunstgalerie die wir defenden müssen
klein aber ich darf hier nicht mal mehr rauf ja das ist ja super sehr nett von dem spiel
aber vielleicht habe ich glück und ich darf wenigstens wenigstens rüber fliegen da ich
bisschen deckung habe ich ich haue einfach mal was in die richtung
ich wollte da gar nicht dran easy easy dachte vielleicht kommt ihr jetzt was aber
ok dann nicht dann nicht alter assault rifles manifest finde ich gut manifest manifest ich
muss sagen manifest ist meine lieblings map manifest ist mein lieblings map ich weiß
nicht was es mit container maps ist was bei da ist da abgeht aber container maps irgendwie
so noch erkennt es kann sich bestimmt noch jeder dran erinnert container maps kriegen
die aus irgendwelchen gründen hin bin mir nicht so genau sicher was damit auf sich hat
aber container maps können sie nicht gut ok was ist hier was ist hier pp gar 29 angesagt
hovercraft man throwing a special ja das musste die welt wirklich jetzt erfahren sonnens ganz
wichtig ganz wichtig throwing a special ok weg hier die kommen von der seite gerade richtig
krass reingefahren gatchi base mein gott alter das spiel so jetzt gibt es nur eins was dagegen
hilft zum glück hält der captain peng ein bisschen die squad fahne diese runde hoch
aber mir geht ja gerade nicht so wirklich was jetzt müssen andere erst erst mal kurz
die falsche naht ich will wieder ja boris boris geh weg ok boris ist weg als ich wollte
kann sagen eigentlich müsste ich webster spielen dass ich ein bisschen hier rum kreppling
hucken kann ich hole dich max ich hole dich weil sonnens ist jetzt hier nicht so der wahnsinn
hier kannst du nicht gescheit fliegen wir können mal gucken ob er hat mal ich mache
jetzt big brain play wobei nee nee ich hab es mir auch nicht so gut ich mach kein big
brain play ich mach ich verpiss mich play aber motion sensor geht noch das ist ja das
ist wahnsinn ok vergesst einfach rao ist unfassbar underrated rao ist der hacker man oder ist
rao der hacker man ich glaube ich habe rao ich glaube rao ist der einzige specialist den
ich noch nie gespielt habe alle anderen habe ich mal ausprobiert den habe ich noch nie
aus der habe ich glaube wie sieht der überhaupt aus den habe ich noch nie mal angeklickt
ach der ist das aber doch den habe ich den habe ich zumindest schon wahrgenommen dass
der existiert das war es aber auch ok next please
ok die runde verdrängen wir einfach wieder ganz schnell gleich
oh nee ich hätte mich retten lassen können oder auch nicht wahrscheinlich wäre dabei
gestorben eh wahrscheinlich ganz ganz gut dass ich mich nicht retten lassen
ok können wir irgendwelche big brain
nein können wir nicht alter nein mensch nein nein das kannst du nicht einfach hier runter
fallen durch alles
das das das war nicht so next level gerade
hier was kann man eigentlich hier drauf ohne dass er runterspringt ok das ist schonmal gut
das ist schonmal gut da hat man vielleicht ein paar bessere ein paar bessere winkel oder
so
vielleicht so nein ach man ich habe nicht nach links gedrückt der hat seine sprunganimation
gemacht
da ist noch overcraft
guck mal ich ich ich mache gar nichts ich ich gehe einfach nur hier hoch
und nee jetzt mag er gar nicht mehr aber das heißt man muss das von hier oben machen ok
ok man diese animation man kann nicht mal aufs geländer das ist ja blöd
das ist echt dumm ok so geht das alles klar
oh man die animation ist wirklich hochgradig pepega warum warum springt er warum springt
er so ins nichts
wer denkt sich das ist eine gute idee ja lass uns einfach mal lass uns einfach mal runterspringen
in den tot
sturmgewehre sehr gute idee
um nichts zu sagen
ich dachte vielleicht kann ich in grappling hook killen
nope aber er hätte ja funktionieren können
hätte es sein können aber
wir könnten das ich wir könnten das sogar schaffen hier weil wir halten das wirklich
gut
kann man sich nicht beschweren ist wirklich ok
wo ist der nächste motion sensor bäm wall bang motion sensor
vielleicht wartet mal vielleicht so
oder auch nicht moment das muss ich jetzt noch mal ausprobieren
die pro moves kommen jetzt hier ah yes yes yes yes exquisite
bleiben sie einfach stehen sehr gut
ok oder auch nicht aber aber fast schon
ah nice guckt euch das sehr gut sehr gut sehr gut
ich bin ich glaube ich bin zu sehr mit dem komischen geländer beschäftigt aber das ist
gut zu wissen dass man da aufs geländer kann
das captain peng macht die runde
sehr gut sehr gut dass das das ist gut zu wissen
ok warum musst du jetzt nachladen
next by a bot
nächster specialist skateboard
bringt die man nicht auf ideen haben die nicht sogar die tony hawke lizenz oder ist
das ubisoft
er ist ubisoft oder
sag mir nicht dass die tony hawke lizenz haben
das kommt die bringen die nicht auf ideen das ist schneller schneller als ihr denkt
ist das am start
ok nice
ok komm raus alter komm raus
wie man so schön sagt heute
ich muss los immer dort wo man nicht
was das hoffn
ob man das hoffn einfach das kann da reinfahren gibt es gibt es hat hat es irgendwelche weaknesses
das hoffn kraft
das kann durch wende fahren das kann wende hochfahren das ist unkaputtbar es hat eine
minigun die alles weg und
glaube nicht
glaube das ist einfach op s designt
die haben noch die star wars lizenz ja ich habe heute gelesen dass angeblich ein neues
battlefront
versucht wurde
den schmackhaft zu machen und sie wollten nicht
das ist natürlich mir egal weil ich bin weder großer star wars fan noch hat mich jetzt
battlefront richtig gefeiert
ah bug ok
aber ich könnte mir vorstellen für die star wars fans ist das nice
wollen wir auch mal einen hovercraft aber wir dürfen keinen hovercraft holen
kann man sterben wenn da auf einen drauf fällt
sekunde das muss man das muss man kratzen captain poggers ist ein game wieder gekrasht
ich meine du kannst halt einfach nichts machen
ich kann die rausschießen mit meinem grappling hook pass mal auf big brain idee
ist eigentlich dieses review bombing laggy team ist das spiel so mies also das spiel
hat sich diese negativen reviews
äh reglich verdient
revive backfack
also beim captain poggers
übrigens das letzte das es gibt nur eine sache wie man alter meine güte
ist es macht mich so fertig
also das spiel hat sie auch nice ehrenmann hier
kommt das hier durch
wo ist es hin
wo ist es wo ist es hovercraft
motion da unten ist es
ha hier kommst du nicht rein hier kommst
hier kommst du nicht rein
was please
äh was denn das 12m auto ist das ein shotgun
ist das ein autoshotgun
das bestimmt ein autoshotgun
weil ansonsten war mir
der hat direkt gefressen
ok hier bleiben wir
leute wir können nicht verlieren solange wir auf dem dach bleiben
es ist so
ihr wisst ihr wisst dass ich recht habe
wir können nicht verlieren solange wir auf dem dach bleiben
keine chance
also die gegner können wir wir können nicht verlieren
geht nicht
also ich hab noch ich hab noch nie verloren
die also ich hab diese map noch nie verloren das ist kein witz
als defender das ist so op ist die posi hier
gleich kommen die hovercraft hochgefahren ja wahrscheinlich
game
gleich kommen die gleich kommen die die aufzüge hier ist schon zu
weil das nix wirklich heißt also sie können von da kommen
also hier kommen aber der geht zu hier kommt gleich einer raus
hier hier ist den zu gleich am start
achtung was hat man sich dabei gedacht
keck weight
schmeißen man motion sensor und schmeißen wir noch mal motion sensor
rüber also die können uns nur helikram
die können uns nur mit helikram bashen
alles andere auf der anderen seite wir sollten mal rüber
auf der anderen seite ist ein bisschen wenig los
da ist eigentlich alles in ordnung
da kommen sie gleich jetzt hier achtung
guck mal da
ah die fahren die fahren auch wieder weg
würde ich auch so machen
wenn ich das sehen würde was hier auf mich abämt
wenn ich finde wenn der wachstuhl aufgeht
würde ich auch gleich wieder runterfahren
direkt direkt rage quit
direkt wieder raus
was die halo beta ist gecrashed
ich habe bisher von allen gehört ist halo
also die infinite multiplayer
der released wurde soll ziemlich ziemlich gut sein
wir losen überhaupt nicht ground
wir gewinnen easy
können wir hovercraft trocken hier oben
ah excellent beste trocken wir hovercraft hier oben drauf
sehr gut
da kann eigentlich nichts mehr schief gehen jetzt
können wir ein paar helis abschießen
ja das ist sehr fair übrigens wenn man jetzt in diesem fahrstuhl spawnt
Leute wo ist der heli ich will den heli baschen
heli
ok leute ich lasse euch ich lasse euch das
macht ihr macht ihr hovercraft action
jawohl guck mal hier das musste den das musste den nicht lange sagen lassen
das musste den nicht lange sagen lassen
das fände übrigens ein bisschen pepega dass man kein neues ich glaube ich zumindest
dass es so ist
dass man kein neues hovercraft spawnen kann solang das alte noch lebt
und man das nicht locken kann also irgendwelche leute können es anrand der map fahren und
dann
abschümmeln lassen
guckt es euch an
wir losen überhaupt kein ground
die gegner können überhaupt nichts machen die sind hoffnungslos
out out wie soll man sagen
out position
wie soll man die nein alter voice voice ansager mann das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht
auch so pepega zeug zu erzählen hier passiert überhaupt gar nichts
meint ihr meint ihr da ist hat das selbst mal gespielt
ach da guck mal da guck mal da
hallo hallo
man kann manchmal manchmal kann man den rausschießen mit dem mit dem grappling hook
ok
ich will das gar nicht haben jetzt kann er kein neues mehr spawnen solange wir das besetzen
hört ihr den ansager der ansager ist selbst verwirrt von dem map design
oh nice nice nice
exzellentes map design meint ihr chat meint ihr da ist hat es gespielt
und also ich kann es so richtig vorstellen da patrick wie heißt das söderlund oder
so
wieder hier oben die den den fahrstuhl abemt kann ich mir richtig gut vorstellen
der ist doch moment das söderlund das ist doch der von von battlefield 5 der da gehen
musste oder ich ich kann mir
bei schweden stels da blick ich dich genau durch ich weiß nur das ist der chat ich weiß
nur das definitiv nicht der marcus söder ist auch immer was das da was das dahinten
game wollte mich verarschen
das da oben jetzt da oben stehen panzer da oben stehen hovercrafts da oben steht alles
rum es sind jetzt halt jetzt ist wieder genau
ein beispiel für das was ich was ich jetzt schon öfters gesagt habe warum breakthrough
probleme hat
das kann man eigentlich hiermit machen
hier sind jetzt gerade 128 spieler
quasi auf einer auf einer close quarters map siebertower von der fläche her ungefähr
siebertower ist noch was meint ihr ist siebertower größer als die zwei dächer oder ist siebertower
kleiner wahrscheinlich siebertower sogar noch größer und du hast 128 spieler die sich
jetzt hier drauf drängeln das ist halt schon
ach guck mal realistisches hovercraft am stand das ist halt schon ziemlich ziemlich pepega
circa gleich wir haben nicht vergessen also siebertower hat auch zwei ebenen und hat in
der mitte noch so einen garten so wo man sich sonnen kann
also wir brauchen sowas natürlich nicht
wisst ihr was wisst ihr was
wir gehen jetzt mal da runter und lassen uns bashen und kommen dann als sundance wieder
rein und stellts mit dem wingsuit ein bisschen rum
alter dieses game
ok mehr ging nicht
ging nicht was soll ich machen erst mal 20 gegner direkt im gesicht
cap'n pogger soll ich dich entweiten nach der runde wieder oder willst du es einlassen
weil es abkackt oh schon spät leute schon spät ich sehe gleich 23 uhr
schon richtig spät
extrem spät boomer müde boomer bett
boomer müde boomer schlafen
ok sehr gut gemacht game abgebounced vom boden habe ich überhaupt nicht mehr durchgeblickt
bonk bonk
wir können ja eh nicht also wir haben ja eh unendlich tickets da können wir so ein scheiß
machen wir werden das hier oben im leben nicht im leben nicht verlieren wir können eigentlich
jetzt dauer re-spawn und und einfach uns irgendwo rein stürzen easy
ist da oben ein auch guck mal da sind welche
ok alles klar hat sich jetzt nicht nicht so verhalten wie ich zumindest gedacht habe
mensch game cheap cheap bade mich doch nicht immer so krass
aber das game hat mich wieder rast gebetet ich lande da es ist nichts und auf einmal bin
ich bin ich in irgendeinem komischen müllhaufen vom heli
aber wir können das ist das ist ja nice also ich meine die pose hier die ist so op die
werden wir im leben nicht verlieren wir stürzen uns jetzt einfach runter und machen ein paar
sinnlosen kills easy ok jetzt jetzt vielleicht jetzt jetzt darf ich vielleicht
jetzt ist hier nichts mehr das ist mir übrigens viel zu vertikal wenn
ich ehrlich bin machen wir mal ein paar spotting dinge runter
overcraft wer hätte das genutzt das schreit sie
warum die redet die kann ich reden die ist dies dead
was nicht vergessen mw war auch wie bf und dann haben sie es bis heute unter support
er spricht er spricht wir spricht wir ok wo sind wir hier
oh Leute Leute da kraschen wir jetzt voll rein wir kraschen so rein und wäschen die
ich zitiere nur battlefield battlefield drei soldaten ja no homo hier wüsste ja also
ne was war ich für ein scheiß hier nix mit nix schlimmes dran gachi bass so viel ihr wollt
quality für ein youtube short das jetzt mit dem heli kill am besten ja mit dem heli mit
dem heli der ist noch ich glaube ich glaube squad eins jaja das ist der da sind die mit
dem heli wahrscheinlich so es drei tage waren auch gott das kann ja heutzutage echt
passieren wegen jedem scheiß ja so ja wir springen einfach wieder vom haus du schaust
schon seit jahren damals seit dem friseur das ist auch cool wie viele leute ihren weg
ja leute soll ich euch sagen heute war heute war jubiläum wir haben jetzt 19.000 mit stellze
auf twitch vielleicht vielleicht ich habe eine idee vielleicht vielleicht haben wir
glück so war das nicht geplant by the way alles klar da ist es bin ich schön zu sehen
auf der map sehr gut und den panzer du kannst dieses spiel nicht kontrolliert spiel das
funktioniert nicht nicht 19k subs knusper klaus danke für den für den zapp 19.000
follower 15.000 follower gibt es irgendjemand den ich hosten soll leute ich gehe nach der
runde wahrscheinlich pennen schon spät boomer müde ja wo landen wir jetzt hier übrigens
hier passiert ja nichts bei dabei passt mal auf hier passiert nichts beim bonk easy überlebt
kein problem kein problem kein problem ja guckt ja realismus pur bonk easy also komplett
wie in echt meine güte was hat man sich dabei gedacht wer dachte ja da brauchen helis und
dann alles wird gebashed mit helis im trailer sah das viel cooler aus das nehme ich ihnen
übel das nehme ich ihnen übel mit dem trailer die haben nämlich quasi ihre treuesten fans
gebated mit dem jet und dem rpg und was sonst noch alles war die haben ihre treuesten fans
gebated und da bin ich ihnen wirklich böse drum dass das spiel so am arsch ist das kann
ich vergessen irgendwann aber dass sie ihre treten dass sie ihre fans sei da am kills jawoll
das muss das war wichtig hervor zu heben da bin ich ihnen böse drum
eigentlich habe ich ja gesagt wir lesen doch ein paar comments unter dem video aber ich
glaube das wird jetzt ein bisschen ein bisschen spät ich gucke mal kurz wen ich hosten kann
ansonsten ich schaue mal schnell wie viel views das video mittlerweile hat das geht ja ganz
gut ab ach ja also für meine verhältnis ist 32k in den ersten paar stunden echt nicht
schlecht so viel habe ich nicht mal zu color shooting
zeiten gekriegt richtig nice so ich schaue mal ist der lost noch on dann hosten wir den
lost aber der wäre irgendwie einen halben tag schon und das glaube ich nicht ne der ist
nicht mehr on wie kann man hosten ich gucke gerade ich gucke gerade wem wem wem ich folge
muss auch nicht unbedingt battlefield sein aber die streamer hier aus aus de sie sind
wahrscheinlich auch alle schon boomer müde boomer schlafen
shroud braucht mein host bestimmt nicht
ne ich finde nicht dass bed company 2 nice ist im portal
und das hat mit bed company 2 überhaupt nichts mehr zu tun ich lade das rage video nicht
anlistet hoch
ne ist keiner da von denen denen ich follow wo ich sagen würde muss jetzt gehostet werden
den ich das letzte mal gehostet habe ist on ich will nicht immer die gleichen leute
hosten ja den hatten wir auch letztens erst gehostet
wisst ihr was ich gehe jetzt einfach ich gehe jetzt auf schon spät betke wir haben
übrigens ein emote dafür falls ihr das noch nicht kennt wir haben wupp betke ganz wichtig
und das mache ich jetzt auch wupp betke falls ihr auch zugriff auf die ganzen nice emotes
haben wollt übrigens die wir haben ein bisschen werbung muss ja sein
hallo was jetzt wenn ihr auch diese ganzen nice da sind übrigens viel mehr das sind
die bette twitch tv emotes weil ich hier nicht subscribed bin wenn die ganzen nice emotes
haben wollt zum beispiel hier wupp pock oder wupp wupp pet
dann würde ich mich natürlich auch sehr über euren prime sub freuen denn ihr wisst ja
ein prime sub steiger den eq vom ganzen chat um ein prozent
ne um einen punkt nicht prozent ok jetzt wirds cringe ich gehe jetzt off leute wir sehen
uns bis denn
danke danke für die ganzen subs nice heute habe ich die hälfte wieder übersehen ich
gucke noch mal kurz rein hier dom torretto ist am start der knusperklaus
mr vip affen haue oxi fabian am start den nils hatten wir schon
danke für die subs bimmy die haben flow the game ich erkenne gewisse ähnlichkeiten
ja danke für die subs leute poggers massive poggers also ansonsten guckt bei mir auf youtube
rein guckt bei mir auf twitch rein guckt bei mir auf twitter rein wenn euch das interessiert
was ich mit dummes treu ich laber wir sehen uns bis zum nächsten mal machts gut see you